with the election just 69 days away
there's a growing effort to stop the
spread of false information
the senate intelligence committee report
on russian interference
in 2016 stated this no single group of
americans was targeted more than
african americans our national
correspondent jerica duncan shows us how
one group
is fighting back on that tarika good
morning to you
good morning when you think back to 2016
i don't think voters or candidates
were prepared for the onslaught of
misinformation
when we sat down with andre banks and
ashley bryant they created an
organization to ensure
that 2020 is different particularly for
black and latino communities
they say their ultimate goal is to make
sure that voters have the tools they
need to fight
misinformation and stay informed
what is happening with our own video on
this how's it performing
where do we actually post it each
morning andre banks and ashley bryant
sign into what they call the war room
to discuss the latest popular posts that
are spreading false information
you all call this a war when you look at
what happened in 2016 this is one of the
biggest campaigns to misinform american
voters
in history you know when you have that
level of strategy on the other side
you want to meet that with a level of
strategy on this side it's important
that black people at next people are
able to make their voices heard this
year
they're co-directors of win black
palante palante means to go forward in
spanish
they work with more than 200 people
across 15 states
mostly swing states to monitor memes
messages
and images across the most popular
social media platforms as the
demographics of this country change
it's critical that we are able to have a
conversation across race
we're able to have democracy where all
kinds of people can show up and we can
come together to make the big decisions
that we need
to move the country forward a senate
intelligence committee report found that
more than
66 percent of information spread online
by russian operatives during the 2016
election
contained a term related to race one
fake account called blacktavis had 11.2
million engagements with facebook users
these groups are impersonating black
folks pretending to be black activists
and they're using the issues that matter
most to us to lure them in
have them thinking that it's a sense of
community and then
they ultimately say we're not going to
vote let's all band together and abstain
from voting
do you think this was the difference
between hillary clinton losing and
donald trump winning the presidential
election in 2016. i think it definitely
contributed to it i think you know
misinformation and disinformation
campaigns
writ large and obviously you know black
and latinx voters are
key uh voting blocks within the
democratic party
you all say this is the modern day poll
tax
for african american and latin ex voters
the weaponization of digital media
is really a large form of voter
suppression voter depression
these are attacks on our communities to
misinform us to disinform
to counter posts that are verifiably
false when black pallante has created
gifts
memes and posts that are true and
factual their library has more than
400 million views what's the most recent
misinformation you found that you've had
to counter
yeah we've been tracking very closely a
range of misinformation about
senator kamala harris and since her
nomination on the democratic ticket
you know part of misinformation is not
just outright lies but really confusing
and muddying the waters
in this case we've seen a lot of the
kind of birtherism that we saw around
obama
would you say a lot of the
misinformation you're trying to counter
impacts voters that are likely to vote
democrat yeah i mean you know the
if you look at the last elections you
know black and latinx voters are
disproportionately have voted for
democrats but if misinformation can
happen to any community
then anybody can be the target of it if
it can be weaponized against black
people it can be weaponized against
women
it can be weaponized against older
americans and so this is something that
we should all
feel a part of trying to stop and trying
to change
when black volante says it gets its
funding from individuals
individual donors rather across the
country you know tony this really comes
down to a part
or a part in our time our history if you
will where it's so important for people
to research the information
that they're getting whether it's
through facebook or twitter and also
listening to the candidates
yeah such an important story jerica and
not only should people be researching
what they hear
but also asking themselves what is the
source of the information
is it trustworthy what that source's
motivation may be
and being skeptical i want to bring
alien on this because
it's absolutely right yeah i was
thinking an era where there is
more information available than at any
time in our history and yet less and
less of it is trustworthy
i know and we're sitting here on a cbs
platform we're in the news business
and i go online and look at some of the
stuff and it's so hard to
believe what you're seeing sometimes you
have to do your own diligence
and most importantly i like what jericho
said listen to the candidates
and question where the information is
coming from it's important that you do
your own due diligence on this because
the people who are spreading the
misinformation
they are very good at it very good that
was a great piece to reach absolutely
right great piece
yeah well done jerica